In order to display your sent memes
evenly across the collection view,
you'll want to set the size
of the custom meme cells, and
the spacing between them.
To accomplish this, we use the class,
UICollectionViewFlowLayout.
Here I've opened the class reference,
and
you can also find a link to
it in the instructor's notes.
I encourage you to take some time
to read through it carefully.
The UICollectionViewFlowLayout class
has three properties it will need for
laying out our sent memes.
Minimum line spacing, minimum
inter-item spacing and item size.
To implement
a UICollectionViewFlowLayout, first, add
a flow layout object to your collection
view controller using this line of code.
Open up the assistant editor so
that you can see the storyboard file.
And then connect the flow layout outlet
to its representation and store reward.
You can see here that it's
marked with a little yellow box.
Next, set the spacing between items
by setting the minimum inter-item
spacing property, like this.
You can see that the variable
space is being set to 3.
Similarly, use the minimum line spacing
property to set the spacing between
rows.
Naturally, you don't need to use 3.
Use whatever spacing
you think looks best.
Last but not least, set the item size.
The item size is the size
of your cells and
I encourage you to set the item
size to be dependent upon
the size of the main view,
which is dependent upon screen size.
That way your layout will work for
multiple screen sizes.
To access the size of the main view,
you can use this, self.view.frame.size.
Here I’m accessing the width property
and you can do the same for height.
So let's see how our layout looks.
Okay, so apart from this one image, the
layout in portrait looks pretty good.
Let's see what it looks
like in landscape.
In landscape you can see that we've got
a little extra space between items.
And I'm going to leave it up to
you to figure out why that is and
get this layout looking
the way you want it.
I'll give you a hint.
One solution involves accessing
the height of the main view,
kind of like the way we
accessed the width here.
And that ought to give you a good
start on collection view flow layouts.